We are defining a random
variable as a real valued
function on the sample space.
So this is a good occasion to
make sure that we understand
what a function is.
To define a function, we
start with two sets.
One set--
call it A--
is the domain of the function.
And we have our second set.
Then a function is a rule that
for any element of A
associates an element of B. And
we use a notation of this
kind to indicate that we are
dealing with a function f that
maps elements of A into
elements of B.
Now, two elements of A may be
mapped to the same element of
B. This is allowed.
What is important, however, is
that every element of A is
mapped to exactly one element
of B, not more.
But it is also possible that
we have some elements of B
that do not correspond to any
of the elements of A.
Now, I said that a function is
a rule that assigns points of
A to points in B. But what
exactly do we mean by a rule?
If we want to be more precise,
a function would
be defined as follows.
It would be defined as a
set of pairs of values.
It would be a set of pairs of
the form x, y such that x is
always an element of A, y is
always an element of B, and
also-- most important--
each x in A appears in
exactly one pair.
So this would be a formal
definition of
what a function is.
It is collection of ordered
pairs of this kind.
As a concrete example, let us
start with the set consisting
of these elements here.
And let B be the set
of real numbers.
And consider the function that
corresponds to what we usually
call the square.
So it's a function that
squares its argument.
Then this function would be
represented by the following
collection of pairs.
So this is the value of x.
And this is the corresponding
value of y.
Any particular x shows
up just once in this
collection of pairs.
But a certain y--
for example, y equal to 1--
shows up twice, because minus
1 and plus 1 both map to the
same element of B.
Now, this is a representation
in terms of ordered pairs.
But we could also think of
the function as being
described by a table.
We could, for instance, put
this information here in a
form of a table of this kind
and say that this table
describes the function.
For any element x, it
tells us what the
corresponding element y is.
However, when the set A is an
infinite set it is not clear
what we might mean by saying
a table, an infinite table,
whereas this definition
in terms of
ordered pairs still applies.
For example, if you're
interested in the function
which is, again, the square
function from the real
numbers, the way you would
specify that function
abstractly would
be as follows.
You could write, it's the set of
all pairs of this form such
that x is a real number.
And now such pairs, of course,
belong to the two dimensional
plane because it's a
pair of numbers.
So this set here can be viewed
as a formal definition or a
specification of the
squaring function.
Now, what this set is
is something that we
can actually plot.
If we go in the two dimensional
plane, the points
of this form are exactly the
points that belong to the
graph of the square function.
So this abstract definition,
really all that it says is
that a function is the
same thing as the
plot of that function.
But it's important here
to make a distinction.
The function is the
entire plot--
so this set here is
the function f--
whereas if I tell you a
specific number x, the
corresponding value here
would be f of x.
So here x is a number and
f of x is also a number.
And those two values, x and f
of x, define this particular
point on this plot.
But the function itself
is the entire plot.
Let us also take this occasion
to talk a little bit about the
notation and the proper way of
talking about functions.
Here is the most common
way that one
would describe a function.
And this is an appropriate
way.
We've described the domain.
We've described the
set on which the
function takes values.
And I'm telling you for any x in
that set what the value of
the function is.
On the other hand, sometimes
people use a more loose
language, such as for example,
they would say,
the function x squared.
What does that mean?
Well, what this means is
exactly this statement.
Now let us consider
this function.
The function f--
again, from the reals
to the reals--
that's defined by f of
z equal to z squared.
Is this a different function
or is it the same function?
It's actually the same function,
because these two
involve the same sets.
And they produce their outputs,
the values of f,
using exactly the same rule.
They take an argument and they
square that argument.
Now, if you were to use informal
notation, you would
be referring to that
second function as
the function z squared.
And now, if you use informal
language, it's less clear that
the function x squared and the
function z squared are one and
the same thing, whereas with
this terminology here, it
would be pretty clear
that we're talking
about the same function.
Finally, suppose that we have
already defined a function.
How should we refer
to it in general?
Should we call it the function
f, or should we say the
function f of x?
Well, when x is a number,
f of x is also a number.
So f of x is not really
a function.
The appropriate language
is this one.
We talk about the function f,
although quite often, people
will abuse language and they
will use this terminology.
But it's important to keep in
mind what we really mean.
The idea is that we need to
think of a function as some
kind of box or even a computer
program, if you wish, that
takes inputs and produces
outputs.
And there's a distinction
between f, which is the box,
from the value f of x that the
function takes if we feed it
with a specific argument.